[Music]
so
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
this thursday morning a police manhunt
continues in liverpool this morning to
find the mass gunman who shot and killed
nine-year-old olivia pratt corbel in her
own home earlier this week we'll be live
in the city where police are questioning
a 35-year-old man who was understood to
be the intended target of the attack
also this morning a nervous day for
students across the country as they
receive their gcse results after sitting
exams for the first time since before
the pandemic
and it could be a disappointing day with
grades expected to be deliberately lower
than last year the school's minister
that's will quince will be with me in
just a moment it's thursday the 25th of
august
a huge manhunt continues in liverpool as
police hunt the gunman who murdered a
nine-year-old girl
police say members of the public have
been coming forward with information as
they question a 35 year old man believed
to be the intended target of the attack
a warning of widening regional
disparities of students across england
wales and northern ireland get their
gcse results this morning
i'm here at the crest academy in north
london where shortly students will be
opening their envelopes
the energy firm british gas says it will
give away 10 of its profits to help
customers struggling to cope with
soaring energy prices as ofgem prepares
to announce the autumn price cap for
bills tomorrow
the uvalde district police chief is
sacked after his forces response to the
texas school massacre when 19 students
and two teachers were murdered
more than 20 people killed and dozens
injured as a russian rocket hits a
ukrainian town
president zielenski has vowed to evict
the evaders the invaders following the
attack which came as ukraine marked its
independence day
conservative party infiltration here in
edinburgh one of the bbc's former top
presenters references tory cronyism at
the heart of the corporation
[Music]
pink floyd reportedly on the verge of
selling their back catalogue in a deal
that could be worth as much as
400 million pounds
which is nice also coming up on the
program for you this morning wherever
you're watching us around the world
speaking to the eastenders star
and strictly dance come dancing winner
that's her rose ailing ellis of course
she preparing to show her experiences as
a deaf actress while delivering the
alternative mctaggart lecture in
edinburgh
business is a competition
a time to be weak
conflict diverse
and i'm concerned you might be
soft the only way he'll respect you and
hearing from succession's patriarch the
man who stars as logan roy brian cox
[Music]
morning police in liverpool are still
searching for a mass gunman who shot and
killed nine-year-old olivia pratt corbil
meanwhile new cctv footage has emerged
clearly capturing the sound of four
gunshots being fired on monday night a
warning this report from our national
correspondent tom palmenta contains that
cctv
and the sound of gunfire which some
viewers may find distressing
olivia's family have asked that these
are the pictures that everyone sees
the bubbly nine-year-old girl whose life
was so needlessly taken on monday
skyler was in olivia's class
they should be starting year five
together in less than two weeks
i think i was actually your best friend
to be honest with you we used to play
two four days and stuff and
i gave her a granny wig
did you yeah and um
give her the
top and jacket to put on did you with
the name granny stick i i so she was
always messing around and having fun
yeah she used to love like
love like play times and stuff she was
quite funny like
the investigation to find those
responsible is moving at pace
the sounds of the gunshots were recorded
[Music]
two shots
and then more
[Music]
[Applause]
as her mom tried to protect olivia on
their doorstep it carried on
the fourth and final shot is followed by
this
at the top of the screen two minutes
later the flashes of feet running away
the first suspect to be detained was the
one who was already in a hospital bed
the 35 year old man who was being chased
in the shooting that led to olivia's
death
he is joseph knee who was out of prison
on license
he was the intended target but only
suffered chest injuries in the shooting
but the police need to identify where
the gunman is
mandy jameson lost her son daniel to
knife crime in liverpool in 2018.
parents need to start listening more to
the kids and they really do takes a
village to check to raise a child
liverpool need to start standing up to
our kids because these kids have taken
over
finding the person responsible and those
who have helped him is the only way
olivia's family will find any sort of
justice while the police have names they
still need more information from these
communities
while their prime suspect
remains at large
tom parmenter sky news liverpool
and we'll have more on that story coming
up throughout the course of the program
here on sky news uh the other main story
for us today though of course is the
gcse students across the country are
receiving their results today with
grades expected to be lower than last
year it's the first time they've been
sat as formal examinations in three
years labour's accused the government of
creating a legacy of unequal outcomes
pointing to regional disparities and
following last week's a-level results
the social mobility charity that's the
sutton trust um they said that the
attainment is uh the gap is uh growing
regional gap is growing uh sabbah is
standing by for us now she's at the
crest academy in northwest london
um hi sam what's the situation there
this morning good morning to you
good morning kay well uh it is still
quite early but in the next hour or so
this uh sports hall in the crest academy
school in north london will be filling
up with students uh opening those
dreaded envelopes to get their gcse
results i remember that time it was a
few some years ago for me now but it was
still
terrifying and i really feel for the
students uh here now something uh that
uh the head teachers union are saying uh
this morning kay is that with uh results
that are coming is that we should really
take them with a pinch of salt they are
uh the first exams that have been sat uh
since uh before the covered pandemic and
they're saying that they are likely to
be lower than the results and the grade
boundaries that we had in place last
year and that's when the teachers were
offering their students predicted uh
grades but if it's any consolation to
parents and students watching uh we know
that the results
this year will be higher than that in
2019 and the union is saying that this
is because of regional disparity so
where coveted infections were higher
this is ultimately where there were less
teachers in schools due to sickness and
also the same with students
so uh good luck to all of those opening
their results this morning
absolutely and so say oliver's education
minister will quince is with us do you
remember opening your exam results i do
22 or so years ago i remember the
nervousness sort of heading into school
to get them yeah when i did it it used
to be actually pinned up on the wall so
everybody could see what your results
were
yeah i know
thankfully i did well in english not so
good in maths uh what is the overall
picture looking like so we'll have to
wait and see um so the results will be
out very very soon but i think the first
thing is date is today is a celebration
of all those young people's achievements
and efforts over the course of the past
two years so today's about saying a huge
well done and a huge thank you to all of
the teachers and the school leaders and
of course parents and carers that are
supported young people to get those
results and you know i wish them every
success with what they go on to do next
their grades are going to be lower
though aren't they so yet they are and
and that's very much part of part of the
plan so over the last couple of years
we've had teacher assessed grades we've
gone back for the first time to
examinations but we've done that in a
staged way so it's not just back to pure
examinations we recognize the fact that
young people have faced huge disruption
of the past couple of years so there
have been adaptations in place and
ofqual have reflected it in their
marking and grading but looking up um
what we put into catch-up funding as
opposed to what other countries do uh
the netherlands um
catch-up funding per pupil was 2100
pounds ours was 310 pounds how can that
be satisfactory so i think it's
difficult to make international
comparisons in that way because we have
very different systems we put in place
around five billion pounds of support
and that's targeted to those who needed
it the most um
we we keep a real watchful eye on these
things and we continue to look at exam
results and things like our education
improvement areas around the country
looking at how we can uh
reduce the attainment
attainment gap and make sure wherever
you live in this country you're getting
a world-class education and the same
opportunity to thrive okay let's keep it
within our borders then if you don't
want to compare it to other countries
close to us um the then
tsar sir kevin collins who had been
asked to come up with his view on how
much government spending should be to
try to improve our education system he
said 15 billion pounds worth of funding
that was totally rejected and he
resigned as a result he did we put in
place uh around five billion pounds of
funding and what i'm not good at so i
said but that's 10 billion less
compared to what he what he asked for at
that time and that's of course the start
we keep this under review and the
previous education secretary and the
current education secretary has said the
same we keep a watchful eye on these
things we continue to invest in
education and if we need to invest more
of course we will but i think what you
know today's about is about celebrating
those gcse results and these young
people up and down the country that
worked incredibly hard we've made
adaptations deliberately to reflect the
fact that young people have faced that
disruption but if you look at the
national tutoring program so some 1.8
billion pound program which continues
now uh that's delivered around 2 million
courses up and down the country those
who we know have got the shortest amount
of time left in education so the 16 to
19 year olds they're getting those extra
40 hours at a cost of some 800 million
so the investment is going in we keep a
watchful life we need to invest more i
have no reservations about going to the
treasury and asking for that so it's
wrong to say that we invest less in
students now than we did in 2010.
so i think that
there are competing arguments on this in
terms of
whether you sort of budgeted inflation
for that but of course you know we
continue to invest i think around an
additional 7 billion pounds over this sr
period so an extra 4 billion pounds into
our school budget this year i think the
overall education budget is around 86
billion pounds so we do invest huge
amounts into into education but as i say
today is about celebrating the success
of all of those gcse students up and
down the country and who are looking
forward to going on taking their next
steps in education what are you putting
regional disparities down to
so i think there are there have always
been uh regional disparities for all
sorts of reasons it's why we've got the
education of the 55
educational investment areas up and down
the country in part it's because there
are some areas of the country where we
find it challenging to attract and
recruit teachers especially high caliber
and high quality teachers so for example
we have the grants in place in some of
those educational attainment areas in
some cases it's around early years the
importance of the the sort of one to one
to five but but we continue to focus on
it because it's huge it's hugely
important that wherever you live is part
of our leveling up agenda wherever you
live in this country you should have
access to a world-class education a
fantastic school in college and go on to
achieve whatever you uh you know your uh
uh your potential is okay now i'm sure
some of our viewers watching this
morning will like me have gone through
the three-day week and the power
blackouts in the 1970s the latest i'm
hearing is that some schools might only
be able to run three days a week because
they cannot afford the energy bills what
are you doing to help them
so a number of things so the first thing
is additional funding so an extra seven
billion pounds over this spending review
period an extra four billion pounds uh
this year so significant bills no of
course it's not so
increase to uh staffing and staff wages
so we keep your watchful eye i mean some
schools will be uh under under long-term
contracts others will be coming out of
those contracts i'm keeping a watchful
eye i listen to schools and school
leaders up and down the country and as i
say we'll be working with the new prime
minister and the new secretary of state
and the new government which we'll have
in just a couple of weeks time uh to
look at some of the challenges we face
and what we may need to do to
acknowledge that some schools might not
be able to open five days a week so no i
don't accept that and we expect schools
to be open five days a week and over 70
percent of schools really do a 32.5 hour
week um the ifs indeed have looked at
schools and and they have said that um
school schools should be able to manage
within their existing budgets but look
i'm alive to the fact that energy costs
are increasing at a significant rate we
see that in our household bills it will
be the same in uh commercial and indeed
schools so keep a very watchful eye and
continue to work
yeah i saw bruce johnson yesterday had
gone to ukraine to offer um his support
the six-month
anniversary if that's the right word of
the invasion by russia and he says that
we need to continue on the path that
we're on because they're paying in blood
we're paying in higher bills what if
people can't afford to pay their high
bills
well i i know how concerned people are
especially ahead of the price cap
announcement uh tomorrow uh what i would
say to them is there is already a 37
billion pound package of support that's
been put in place not enough though well
most of which hasn't actually come into
effect yet so the 400 pounds for every
household we've had the first 300 pound
cost of living payment there will be a
second one towards the end of this year
150 pounds for pensioners 150 pounds for
those who on
disability benefits and and that's
exactly why the government has always
said and indeed both of the leadership
contenders have said that their first
act will be a fiscal event where they
will look at what more support we can
provide to people but as i say that 37
billion pound package support is in
place 400 pounds for every household
coming in the autumn but i know how
worried people are about it and more
support will come and i say i'm pleased
to see that both leadership contenders
and we'll have a new prime minister in
just a couple of weeks time their number
one priority alongside their chancellor
will be to support people through this
now i know that you um you're not really
got involved in the leadership um debate
and
so i used support wishes soon out but
i've not heard you speak too much about
it but i do want to put this to you
because you are a conservative
senior minister
um a senior ally of liz trust has said
this morning that sunak is thrashing
around all over the place like a wounded
stoat his attacks um a weasel if you
don't know what one is his attacks are
framing us as tori scum
this is not what you need is it well i i
haven't i haven't seen seen this in the
times
well i haven't seen i haven't seen those
comments as it was nearly starting
smaller so i haven't read okay i've read
the times check my word for what i will
do okay but what i would say on that is
one of the things that i found most
difficult about the leadership contest
has been the sort of blue on blue which
i think is totally unnecessary both
candidates should just present their
positive vision for our country and the
most important thing is that in two
weeks time so on on tuesday the sixth
when we have a new prime minister that
we all as a parliamentary party get
behind that new leader get behind that
prime minister and we continue to
deliver for the british people that's
what i want to see do you think boris
johnson has done enough in this period
between him stepping down and the new
minister the new prime minister taking
over it's been described as a zombie
government on more than one occasion
yeah i don't recognize that that picture
and certainly from an education
perspective we've been working hard on
exam results the work that we'd started
around the send review around the uh the
green paper the the work we're doing
around reforming children social care
that has all continued and it will
continue to continue and hard-working
civil servants alongside ministers up
and down uh whitehall are working to
ensure that the new government will be
we're not just going to be starting from
fresh they will have a suite of options
that they'll be able to take forward
alongside ongoing 2019 manifesto
commitments that we are yet to deliver
and working hard on so i don't recognize
the picture that's painted and as far as
i'm concerned the prime minister has
always shown a massive interest in
education and what i've been doing both
in the children families brief and also
in the schools brief and i've no doubt
he'd continue to do so even though he's
working from home his country home
mostly um let's end where we started and
uh a word for those that don't get the
gcse results they're hoping for so don't
panic it really isn't the end of the
world that there have never been more
options for post 16 than there are now
so whether you go on to do a levels t
levels which is our exciting new uh
technical vocational qualifier
qualification whether you go on to
further education whether you go on to
an apprenticeship which will probably
more and more popular
there are so many options to you don't
panic speak to your college uh speak
speak to your parents uh you will be
able to achieve your potential just
don't panic how did you do
i it was a long time ago i got six a's
and four b's as i did
um
a levels didn't go quite quite so well
right but i really enjoyed my my time at
school and that's the most important
thing you know your grades are important
but they don't define you
just have a plan b i hope you all young
people down the country get the grades
they want to need today if you don't
don't panic there are so many options
open to you good to see you mister
thanks very much thank you quick look at
what the papers are saying this morning
mixed picture on the front page is the
sun reporting that the only man arrested
so far in connection with the murder of
nine-year-old olivia pratt corbil is
refusing to help police the headline for
the sake of little olivia talk
the telegraph has comments about the
cost of the war in ukraine from boris
johnson while visiting the country we're
paying higher bills ukraine is paying in
blood he says
ahead of the announcement tomorrow on
the energy price cap the murrah carries
this message from the people of britain
freeze our bills now
while the times reports on the alarm in
the nhs over liz trust's plan if she
becomes prime minister to divert 10
billion pounds a year into social care
still to come on the program for you
this morning as students await their
gcse results joined by labour's shadow
education secretary stephen morgan
eastenders star and strictly star she's
the winner of course rose ailing ellis
will join me as she prepares to share
her experiences as a deaf actress while
delivering the alternative mctaggart
lecture
[Music]
following the murder of nine-year-old
olivia pratt corbil in liverpool
speaking to the boxers tony bellew and
molly mccann about their weapons down
gloves up initiative aimed at tackling
violent crime in the city
before that some of today's other
headlines and british gas will give 10
of its profits to help vulnerable
customers struggling with soaring energy
bills its parent company that centrica
says the assistance will be provided for
as long as the energy crisis lasts it'll
make an immediate cash injection of 12
million pounds to the british gas energy
support fund to which customers can
apply for a grant to help with their
energy bills
economists have warned that the cost of
living crisis risks putting families
financial and physical health under
threat this winter the resolution
foundation is calling for radical
solutions from the new prime minister
the think tank says the new leader needs
to think the unthinkable to help people
most in need will be speaking to their
chief economist very shortly
and the police chief at a texas school
district has been fired over a mass
shooting in may when 19 students and two
teachers were killed the uvalde
district's board of trustees voted to
dismiss pete arredondo who was accused
of making several critical mistakes
police waited more than an hour to
confront
and kill the gunman
i have messages for peter
and all the law enforcement that were
there that date turn in your badge and
step down you don't deserve to wear one
kobe bryant's widow has been awarded 16
million dollars after first responders
took and shared graphic photographs from
the site of the helicopter crash that
killed the basketball star their teenage
daughter and six others
a court in the u.s found that los
angeles county must pay damages
and the government has said it will work
with albania to quickly process and
repatriate the large number of albanians
crossing the english channel in small
boats
under the proposals albanian police
could be brought to the uk to observe
arrivals and pass on intelligence
now if you thought you'd forgotten the
french that you learned back in school
then think again research by the
university of york find those who
studied the language 50 years ago had
similar recall to students who'd just
done their exams even if they'd never
used it before or since and study
participants were particularly good at
remembering the right foreign words in
emergencies
je m'appelle
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
says 22 people have been killed by a
russian missile strike on a train
station in the country's east russia
hasn't commented on the incident but
since its invasion has insisted that it
doesn't target civilians our defense and
security editor deborah haynes is in the
southern city of odessa for us this
morning um hello deborah good morning um
we were expecting something this was
particularly brutal
yes so western sources have been saying
that they expected russia to
start targeting targeting civilian
infrastructure in the run-up to
independence day yesterday which
obviously also marking six months of
this large-scale war here in ukraine and
this attack in this small town west of
the eastern region of donetsk there was
a missile strike against the house which
killed a boy and then this um deadly
strike against a railway station setting
a train ablaze and killing at least 21
people many more injured the u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken he
tweeted last night saying that while
russia avoided targeting cities such as
kiev they went after the frontline areas
including also kharkiv in the east
mikolayev in the south and it really is
a reminder that six months in to this
large-scale invasion there is no sign of
the war ending and very much questions
about what happens next whether western
support will prevail whether the
ukrainian forces will be able to do as
their president has said they want to
and push russian forces out of the
country definitively
okay for now thank you
one of bbc's former star presenters has
hit out at what she referred to as tory
cronyism at the heart of the corporation
delivering one of the main media
speeches of the year at the edinburgh tv
festival emily maitlis claimed the bbc
board has been infiltrated by what she
called a conservative party agent
put this in the context
of the bbc board
where another active agent of the
conservative party a former downing
street spin doctor and former advisor to
bbc rival gb news now sits
acting as the arbiter of bbc
impartiality
according to the financial times he's
attempted to block the appointment of
journalists he considers damaging to
government relations
well our arts and entertainment
correspondent katie spencer is at the
festival in edinburgh hi katie how did
that go down
morning well look it's quite a quite a
claim to make from a former employee
isn't it she started that speech last
night by saying she didn't want to come
across as someone that used to work for
the bbc that was ranting but that she
felt that having left the bbc she was a
lot more freer to kind of raise some of
these issues that had been bothering her
for quite some time we should say that
that claim that she made in particular
we put that to the bbc they said it's
absolutely not true they uh go out their
way to make sure that everyone on the
board is impartial and that is the
purpose of having the board itself but
claims
really the emily maitlis felt that was
going on now at the bbc that there is
this um
really attempt to pacify downing street
if you like by the bbc in her opinion
the other main thrust of her uh the
theme of that she was making uh
yesterday in her speech was about
impartiality and how all journalists at
the moment she felt were going out of
their way to try and not come across as
being biased because she
feels that
everyone is terrified within the
industry of seeming biased and so there
is this element of uh almost sort of
superficially creating balance and how
that in itself is obscuring the truth so
really interesting uh speech that she
gave last night and certainly i think
within the bbc yeah a lot of eyes rolled
at some of the claims that she was
making
bbc was the focus yesterday on day one
of the tv festival what we're going to
be talking about here today later i
think is really channel 4. channel 4's
uh chief
content officer ian katz is due to give
a talk this morning obviously with
privatization looming and it's still
being unclear what who the next pm is
and what their approach will be to
privatization i think all eyes will be
on that tour this morning also ian katz
is going to be on ian king who's doing a
live special here this morning so that's
going to be one to watch okay thank you
i'm chatting to brian cox actually from
succession fame uh logan roy that coming
up as well later on in the programme
before that though
how do you remember this song
[Music]
rock group pink floyd reported to be on
the verge of a 400 million pound deal to
sell their back catalogue a number of
music companies are believed to be
bidding for the rights to the band's
music including the us private equity
group blackstone and several record
companies
look at the weather
memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
today we'll bring some much needed rain
to the southeast but the bank holiday
weekend looks mainly dry
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now the way google calculates the
climate impact of your flights has
changed so it appears they have less
impact on the environment than they did
before the world's biggest search engine
has taken a key driver of global warming
out of its online carbon flight
calculator but some experts say google's
calculations now represent just over
half of the real impact
on the climate of flights the company
hosts 90 of online searches meaning this
could have wide repercussions on travel
decisions google said it made the change
following consultations with its
industry partners
and with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's have a
look at the impact of climate change on
the planet the right half of the screen
shows how the uk's power is currently
being produced a lot of gas at the
moment renewables not doing quite so
well nuclear there coal we are phasing
out coal as you can see um and then if
we move to this side of the screen this
is the global warming in uh
as far as a number is concerned in
degrees since 1880 that's when modern
records began
1.25 remember that number 1.5 degrees is
potentially the point of no return and
these are our co2 emissions in millions
of tons in real time according to the
university of oxford so that is how that
looks
looking at some of the interesting
pictures in the news for you this
morning looks like this starting with
the former health secretary matt hancock
he thinks he looks like this
this is his avatar apparently um he's
joined the metaverse where he um
obviously
that's what he thinks he looks like i'm
not going to say any more than that
moving on quickly
here we go
uh talking about ukraine a new report
from the resolution foundation was that
people's physical health
is um
being impacted um
by what is happening and not only in
ukraine but also in other parts of the
world as well this is the independence
day celebrations there yesterday but
ukrainians gathered in force to mark the
occasion in edinburgh the event as we
know coincided with the six month
anniversary of the
war and finally
this is um sylvester stallone it's his
newest tattoo
here that used to be a picture of his
wife
on his arm now
is an image of his dog
they've apparently having marriage
difficulties that's the way she found
out
there we are um goodness me
i don't know what he's saying about i
don't know i don't know
fascinating though isn't it still to
come on the program wherever you go
you're tiptoeing through the raindrops
with that one aren't you still to come a
new report from the resolution
foundation warning that people's
physical health is under threat by the
cost of living crisis speaking to the
think tank next
[Music]
hello again everybody welcome back to
the programme uh returning to liverpool
now where police are continuing to hunt
for the gunman who shot and killed
nine-year-old olivia pratt corbel at her
home fraser is with us he's been there
all week of course bringing us the very
latest information um fraser lots of
people stopping me to say how's her mom
well at the moment still recovering she
received treatment for the gunshot wound
gunshot wound to her wrist that same
bullet passing through her wrist and
into her daughter olivia's chest so a
stable condition that's as much as we
can say
at the moment in the meantime we're into
day three now with this murder
investigation and manhunt we know the
identity now of the 35 year old man who
was arrested by police in aintree
hospital yesterday 35 year old joseph
knee he's from the dovecote area here he
was unlicensed he's been arrested on
breach of that licence he was given a
45-month prison term back in july 2018
and was released last year a
straightforward release from that prison
sentence that was for two counts of
burglary for various vehicle crimes
including driving while disqualified and
driving without insurance he actually
hearing two of his colleagues led to the
police on a high-speed chase the
incident where he was arrested and which
he was subsequently jailed for he's also
got previous convictions for drug
offences as well the police will
continue talking to him today they'll
want to know a great deal of information
from him of course they will
be asking him whether or not he knows
the identity of his attacker they'll
want to know the details of the second
man the man that he was walking her down
this road with when they were initially
attacked by the gunman they'll also want
to know details of his accomplices the
accomplices who came here in a
dark-colored audi car helped him took
him to hospital and left olivia dying
police say that they have
now got a number of leads to follow
they've been getting good information
from the public people have been coming
forward with names coming forward with
potential leads there's an awful lot of
ways for them to to follow up they'll
also be scouring more cctv footage we've
seen the cctv footage that's been uh
released that we've that sky news has
released today where it's absolutely
chilling to hear those four gunshots and
to know that one of those gunshots was
the one that took a nine-year-old girl's
life so the police investigation
gathering pace information continuing to
come in and they'll continue to question
35 year old joseph knee in entry
hospital hoping that he can give them
the the piece of vital information that
they need in order to catch the gunman
who carried out this vicious and callous
attack okay fraser thank you
i'm following a warning that people
could be at risk of physical harm this
winter with the soaring cost of living
the minister this morning has said he
knows how worried people are and promise
that more support is on the way here's
what will quince told me a little
earlier
that 37 billion pound package support is
in place 400 pounds for every household
coming in the autumn but i know how
worried people are about it and more
support will come and i say i'm pleased
to see that both leadership contenders
and we'll have a new prime minister in
just a couple of weeks time their number
one priority alongside their chancellor
will be to support people through this
tamara's here didn't tell us whether
there was more money coming though today
no he didn't and this is the background
list of course we're expecting the
off-gem price cap tomorrow how much
people will pay for their energy in the
coming months and we're expecting it's
going to be somewhere in the order of
three and a half thousand pounds and for
many people that is going to be simply
unaffordable and although the two
leadership candidates the two people who
want to be our prime minister have both
talked about helping people we have not
had any idea of what scale of help may
be coming now boris johnson who visited
kiev yesterday said there that the
ukrainians have been paying in blood for
vladimir putin's war but british people
would be paying on their energy bills
now the prime minister has said that
whoever succeeds him in two weeks time
will have to give more help to families
but he said yesterday he suggested
yesterday this is the price that must be
paid for the ukraine conflict and it's
going to be a tough time for families
going forward now as people wait
anxiously to see what kind of support
may be on offer in addition to what's
already been announced and some
significant measures have already been
announced we hear this morning some
interesting news from british gas who
say that they are going to donate 10 of
their profits they make pretty
significant profits to a fund for fuel
poor customers so that's about 12
million pounds and people will be able
to apply for grants of up to 750 pounds
so
not going to solve the whole problem by
any means but it's the first time an
energy company said look we're going to
dip into our own profits in order to try
and help people and surely that throws
down the gauntlet to the government to
try and help people yet further okay so
we were reflecting on that earlier on in
the program and tell people how they
could go about receiving those funds
we'll see you in an hour thanks very
much indeed economists have warned that
the cost of living crisis risks putting
families financial and physical health
under threat this winter the resolution
foundation calling for radical solutions
from the new prime minister the think
tank says the new leader needs to think
the unthinkable to help people most in
need joined now by the chief economist
at the resolution foundation that's mike
bro hello to you mr brewer thank you for
joining us what do they have to do to
think the unthinkable
well first of all they need to realize
that this is a
huge crisis coming our way
uh with with bills due from january that
will be quite simply unaffordable for
for many households and when i say
unaffordable what i mean is people just
will not be able to turn their heating
on uh if prices come out of gym
forecasts and if the government doesn't
do very more people don't turn their
heating on during the winter that that
will mean uh more deaths through cold
weather
yes so when you actually talk about a
catastrophe coming this winter uh
causing serious physical and financial
damage that's what you're talking about
when you talk about physical damage
yes that's right uh the the scale of the
bill so with the typical household in
january on current forecasts will need
to find 600 pounds in january uh to heat
their home and cook their food
and there will be many households in
this country who do not just do not have
600 pounds spare to put onto fuel for
your typical prepayment meet a customer
that is that's half their typical income
and that's former that's we're talking
about four million households there so
that's who we are most worried about
people who sort of can't borrow can't go
in arrears uh so yes though there's a ve
uh
for other people who will find difficult
they'll be going they'll be going to
arrears perhaps they'll miss a payment
and we know that brings risks of of
mental health and stress so yeah this is
this has sort of gone beyond um
households needing to cut back here and
there and maybe you know save a little
you know maybe make her out a bit less
this is this is a current price is a
current this is risking uh people's
physical and mental health during the
winter
ms trust has talked um endlessly about
uh reversing the national insurance rise
will that help
well no one no conservative candidate
has really yet grasped the scale of a
challenge or told us what they will do
to address the scale of the challenge uh
liz truss is very keen on cutting taxes
but you can't solve a energy price
crisis by cutting taxes the the issue we
have with the national insurance cuts is
that about 15 percent of the gains go to
the bottom half of the distribution it
just doesn't work to support the people
uh who need it most uh this winter
what about rishi sunak's plan to
push five billion pounds to poorer
households
so in essence rishi sunak is proposing
to carry on what the government's been
doing so far um with mobile we've we've
got some universal grants going to
everybody we're about to get all back to
get 400 pounds of energy bills and there
have been targeted top-ups for those on
benefits and he'd like to spend another
five billion pounds he's told us doing
more of those targeted top-ups on me and
says it benefits
that is a fantastic way at getting help
to those who need it most uh to the to
the seven or so million households who
are on these as a benefits uh who will
definitely struggle the most without it
um five billion pounds though is not
really going to cut it that that will
pay for another 650 pound round of
grants uh to people um but that that
doesn't cover the amount by which bills
have gone up uh you know since the
government last sort of came to a view
on these things back in may so i think
that that's a good start but i think he
you know even if he was prime minister
he would need to do more
you're talking about the foundation
suggesting a solidarity
tax which is uh basically an increase in
um
our the tax that we pay
yes that's right i i think
well boris johnson actually kind of put
it put it really well yesterday you know
this is a global crisis a global shock
to the economy
um which will make the country poorer as
a result
um and and we thought you know to us
this is this reminds us of of instances
in the past where again the uk has been
hit by tremendous external shocks and in
and in times of in times of war or in
other european countries we look at
germany times where they had the
reunification in the early 1990s at
times where there are big external
shocks and the country is going to be
made poorer
then the tax system is one way to make
sure the burden of that shock is shared
fairly
um
this the the scalars energy price crisis
just keeps getting bigger and bigger and
bigger um and i don't think we've had an
enough discussion about well how as a
country are we going to cope um
i've already told you that spending five
billion pounds is not going to do it um
the labor party proposing to spend
suggest spending 30 billion pounds but
that's just for six months if this goes
on for years then you know yes we're
talking about the government spending
many tens of billions of pounds
protecting the oil from the crisis and
if it's a shock of that magnitude then
we have to also think seriously about
how we're going to pay for that and i
say at times of big external shocks on
us we think that the tax system through
some extra solidarity tax is a good way
of sharing that burden fairly
but a rise in income tax um according to
liz trust
will stifle economic growth
well the risk right now is not a lack of
economic growth the risk right now is
that high energy prices push people into
into debt destitution and hardship so
first of all we must solve the energy
price crisis and as i say there is no
getting around the fact that the energy
price crisis makes us poorer as a
country and so somebody has to pay for
that uh right we can either we can
either put the burden on bill payers now
which will push low households into debt
uh we could borrow but that's just kind
of kicking the can down and asking
future taxpayers to pay or we could use
try and use the tax system to recoup
some of the cost of helping people
through the energy price crisis by
putting the burden on those people who
are most most able to share it we do
need growth um and and and it may be
that reforms corporation tax will get us
growth in the future but right now the
focus has to be on getting getting
through the winter where we're very
worried but also thinking about what
what what the country will do if energy
prices remain high for say the next two
or three years
okay good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed for joining us
okay
well let's stay with those soaring
energy bills should we join now by uh
ross glover the development director for
igas energy hello to you thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
um
what's your view
what do you think the
next prime minister should be doing as
is his or her number one priority
well i mean quite clearly from the
discussion this morning it's got to be
around energy security
affordability of that energy
and right now the uk faces um you know
what one of its highest sort of risks of
supply loss you've got multiple black
swan events all occurring simultaneously
um and really whether we get
gas into the country is whether we can
outbid 42 or 43 other countries around
the world
um for lng cargos all while we're
sitting on a nationally significant
resource of shale gas
across the north of england
uh do you think fracking's the way
forward
it's not an either or i think we need
more of everything we need more solar we
need more wind we need more
geothermal energy for heat supply
we need more
domestically produced gas and in the
north of england there are nationally
significant quantities of that gas under
our feet
uh why is there such controversy around
fracking do you think
um i think it's it's um there is a
huge amount of um
sort of fuel poured on the fire around
the actual effects
of fracking
i think ultimately um
[Music]
if if you look at the the local effects
um they are fairly limited uh especially
with some of the regulation that we have
in the uk it's a very um you know very
controlled development and in fact to be
perfectly frank with you at the moment
um
constrained development which is why we
haven't been able to unlock this um this
this uh strategic resource
okay what what's your
what's your advice to people
who not just in the uk but right around
europe and indeed i'm sure around the
world as well that they're looking at
their energy bills and they're thinking
this is can only get wes get worse i
should say over the next couple of years
at least have we left it too late to
look at things like fracking and
renewables etc
i mean i think
well ultimately it would have been great
if we'd started 10 years ago
and and had the right policy support in
place to be able to to do that
we haven't um now is the right time to
start um we can you know if we have the
right policy support in place um and of
course the the
moratorium on fracking is lifted we can
start to produce um you know very
significant quantities of shale gas um
within a two three year time frame
um it's not too late and i think that
you you did hit the nail on the head
there we say you know looking one two
three years into the future this is not
a this winter and next winter problem
this is a problem that is that could
become embedded within our energy system
okay it's good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time to join us
gcsc uh students receiving their grades
this morning remember when you were
doing that well the association of
school and college leaders has said
they're likely to be uneven across
different schools and areas and reflect
the turbulent circumstances of the
pandemic joined now by their general
secretary of the ascl and that's jeff
barton hi good morning thank you for
joining us so tell me about regional
disparities
i think that's what we're likely to see
there's been all kinds of speculation
about what has covered done what's the
effect been what kind of catch-up do
young people need i think today we're
going to both see the gcses the btx etc
but we're also going to see something
else and it's rather nerdy or other
technical but something called the
national reference test which is a
separate test done by by a sample of
young people that's going to help us to
be able to illuminate whether for
example young people in the northeast
have been more badly affected than those
in the southeast so how would they be
they would be because they missed more
time and therefore their literacy their
numeracy which is what those tests test
uh are lower standards uh that will help
us i think to be able to get a
government which is talked rhetorically
endlessly about helping young people to
actually say we need to do more
specifically in specific areas i think
we owe it to those young people to do
that kind of thing when i put that to
the minister earlier this morning he
said that one of the challenges was the
quality and the number of teachers in
different parts of the country that that
is absolutely true and that that has
been the case and it's a government that
has missed its recruitment targets every
year for the past seven years so we we
definitely know there's an issue both
about recruiting teachers and retaining
teachers partly that is a regional issue
partly it's more significant than that
it's the kind of schools that need
teachers to go and to stay teaching
there the kind of people i represent
leaders to go and commit to staying in
those places are often put off that
because of the punitive nature of
accountability that is the way we
measure schools so there's a whole range
of things which we'll need i think to
change if we're going to attract people
to those areas today is a day to say
well done to those young people but
equally to say this is not the end of
the the line there will be extra support
for some young people some school
teachers some leaders in some areas do
we invest
as satisfactorily enough in this country
as they do in other countries in europe
we don't and we've seen a very specific
example of that and we recently with sir
kevin collins he was appointed as the
catch-up commissioner there he made very
reasonable proposals in terms of what
every young person should be entitled to
for catch-up it was dismissed he
resigned now there was a specific
example where if you compared what we
were doing in this country in england
specifically compared to say the
netherlands compared to the usa very
significantly more investment and even
where we have had a catch-up programme
one-to-one tuition and so on it is
labyrinthine in its complexity so that
many of the people i represent to say
we're giving up on that we're just going
to try and do it ourselves except that
we haven't got enough funding to be able
to do it properly okay um i also put to
the minister that uh funding now uh was
not as high as it was
per student uh in 2010 he disputed that
yes uh they they do and you'll have had
the seven billion pounds being put into
education figure presumably
so let's not listen to the ministers
don't listen to me listen to the
institute for fiscal studies and what
they're saying is by 2024 on the current
investment in education we will be
spending three percent less than in 2010
and yet we are expecting more of our
scores than we did in 2010. it's frankly
not good enough and in the run-up to a
general election i think one of the
things we will see is parents who've had
a window into education opened up for
them who've seen the work of teachers
will be saying frankly it's not good
enough for my child in my area and we
need to see proper investment
nobody's calling for just throwing money
money endlessly but this is an
investment in our young people and today
will illuminate that some of them really
need greater support from us and what
are your people telling you about the
challenges as far as energy costs are
concerned again i put that to the
minister um the suggestions that some
schools could be down to three days a
week he said that he didn't accept that
premise
well i take the first part of the
premise which is energy costs are
eye-watering and a very significant
issue and of course if you're a school
leader and you suddenly see an increase
of 200 in your energy cost what what do
you do
well you can do three things you can
increase class sizes because then you've
got fewer teachers to pay so it reduced
your cost slightly you can cut some
courses we're seeing that today so gcse
music for example a level german smaller
courses because that means you're not
paying those teachers or you can start
to cut support staff teaching assistants
the very people who if you don't
understand mr barton's english lesson
maybe that teaching assistant one to one
can help you to do it so the most
vulnerable young people on the watch of
a government that bangs on about
leveling up will pay the price for that
the energy cost thing is driving that as
well as staffing costs it won't be fixed
by saying let's go to four days a week
or three days a week i think that's a
spurious story because you would still
be paying those staff salaries and all
it would do is perhaps save you one day
of having the lights on i think it's a
kind of side issue okay uh i thought for
those kids that may not get the results
they're hoping for well i think those of
us of a certain age and certainly people
who've been in education realize that
results
are important as a stepping stone to the
next stage of your education career but
ultimately
don't fixate on the grade
talk about your destination and if today
you're disappointed with your grades
there are people in your school in your
college who know you who know the place
that you want to go to and will do
everything they can to make sure you get
onto the right course and you will look
back and think even if it was
disappointing on that day i'm doing the
thing that i wanted to be able to do and
if you look at your results and you
think that's not what i wanted and the
blind panic descends
who do you turn to first
you turn to the members of staff who
will be in school every school and every
college will have people who know you
who have taught you who will be able to
give you advice who like me seasoned
veterans have seen it before and will be
able to just reassure you and help you
to get to the next stage of your
education we're chatting to um a young
man a little bit later on on the program
who is opening up his exam results for
us he is 92 years old
looking forward to that he's lifelong
learning yeah he's been studying maths
via zoom looking forward to hearing from
him it's great to see you thanks very
much indeed is it the weather for it
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well today we'll bring some much-needed
ready was absolutely bucketing down this
morning let me tell you in the southeast
but the bank holiday weekend looks
mainly dry
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now sir elton john has shared a preview
of his collaboration with britney spears
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tiny dancer on his instagram set elton
john tease their new song hold me closer
singing along in a dj booth in cam the
collaboration is due to be released
later this week and mark's britney's
return to making music i'm guessing it's
tiny dancer because that's the line
isn't it anyway hope it is and a giant
outdoor slide in detroit that reopened
for the first time in two years was
quickly closed again after this happened
whoa
that's not good is it
no interest were reported but this video
of children tumbling at high speed on
the way down the 40-foot high slide and
the organizers said fair enough get rid
of that bit like this show see in a
second
[Music]